Let us solve some of the problems of complex variations, and these
Variables are more than one group
Restrictions
You'll see what I'm talking about quickly
If my first issue is -5 <
= x - 4 <= 13
If we have my group, the group is limited to x
Which achieve these equations
x - 4 must be greater than or equal to -5
And x - 4 must be less than or equal to 13
So we can rewrite this composite variant as follows
-5 <= x - 4, and x
- 4 <= 13
And then we can solve each one individually, then that
We must remember that these "and" exist to think about
Set the solution because it should be something that accomplishes these
Equation and equation
So let's solve each other separately
If these, we can add 4
For both ends of equation
In the left side we have -5 + 4 = -1
-1 <= x, is not it?
These 4 are deleted from here and we have x left
On the right side
If the left side, ie this part, simplifies to x
> = -1, or -1
<= x
If we can also write it like this
x> = -1
Both are equal
I just reversed the sides
Now let's do the other condition in green
Let us add 4 to the ends of this equation
In the left side, we have only x
Then in the right hand we have 13+
14, ie 17
If we get x <= 17
If our two conditions are x> =
-1 and x <= 1
If we can write it again
Mixed vehicle if we want it
We can say that the set solution, is that x should be less
Of or equal to 17 and greater than or equal to
-1
You must check both of these conditions
So how will this look on the setup line?
Let's put the line up here
We assume that this is the 17th
Perhaps this is 18
We keep going
Maybe this is 0
I'm clearly jumping from the numbers in the middle
Then we have -1 here, maybe this
If x> = -1, so
We will start from -1
We will surround it with a circle because we have bigger than
Or equal to
x is bigger than that, but it should be less
Of or equal to 17
If it can equal 17 or less than 17
This is the solution set, it's all about
I shaded it orange
If you want to write it in a period format, it will
X is between -1 and 17, and it can also be equal
-1, so we put the arc, and
Can be equal to 17
If this is the period of these
Differentiated composite
Let's solve one another
Let me put a good issue here
Suppose we have -12
I will change the matter a bit about
Which I found here
-12 <- 5x <
= 7
I want to solve a matter containing less than
Less than or equal to
The issue in the book I am browsing contains
It's an equal sign here, but I want to remove it deliberately
Because I want to make it clear to you when we have it
Hybrid mode, ie when we have both symbols
First, we can separate these into two normal variations
We have these disparate here
We know that -12 must be less than 2 - 5x
That must be achieved, and - let me write it down
In another color - these disparities also have to be achieved
2 - 5x must be less than 7 and larger than 12, less
Of or equal to 7 and greater than -12, if and 2
- 5x must be less than or equal to
So let's just solve this way we used to solve everything
Let's put this 2 on the left side
So let's subtract 2 from both ends of this equation
If we subtract 2 from both ends of this equation, the
The left side becomes -14 <
- These are deleted - <-5x
Now let's divide both sides on -5
Remember, when we multiply or divide on
The negative number, it is reversed, is different
If we divide both sides on -5, we will get
-14 / -5, and we have x on the right side
If we divide it by -5, this is reversed
From the signal less than to the greater than
The negative signals are deleted, and we get 14/5>
x, or x <14/5, which is - what is this?
This is 4/5
x <2 4/5
You have written this incorrect fraction in a composite number
Now let's deal with the other limitation
Here in purple
Let's subtract 2 from both ends of this equation
As we did before
In fact, you can deal with them together, but it will
It is confusing
In order to avoid unintended mistakes, I urge you to separate them
in this way
If we subtract 2 from both ends of the equation
The left side becomes -5x
On the right side, we have less than or equal to
The right side becomes 7 - 2, which becomes 5
Now, divide both sides on -5
On the left side we get x
In the right hand side, 5 -5 -5 =
-1
Since we divided the negative number, we will reflect
Differentiated
It will be less than or equal to, bigger
Of or equal to
If it becomes our constraint
x <2 4/5, and x>
= -1
So we can write it like this
x> = -1, hence this
The limit will be the least in period, and x
<2 4/5
And note, it is not less than or equal to
That's why I wanted to make it clear to you, that we have arcs
Here it can not equal 2 4/5
x must be less than 2 4/5
Or we could write that way
x should be less than 2 4/5, these are
Differentiated, reverse sides, must be
Greater than or equal to -1
If these two sentences are equal
And if you want to draw it on the line of preparation
It will look like this
If we have -1, 2/4 here
Clearly we have a set in the middle
Maybe, you know, zero is here
Must be greater than or equal to -1, if possible
It equals -1
It will be bigger than -1, but also
Must be less than 2 4/5
So we can not include 2 4/5 here
It can not equal 2 4/5, if it can only be less
Of, so we put a blank circle around 2 4/5 and then
We fill everything down, down to
-1, and include -1 because we have a lower signal than
Or equal to these
If the last two issues you resolved were "and"
We have to follow all of this video
Now let's solve an issue that contains "or"
Let's assume that I have these variants
Suppose I was given - let's assume that 4x - 1
> = 7, or that is 9x / 2
<3
If now when we say "or", and x that can achieve these
Is the x that achieves any of these equations
In the previous few presentations or in previous issues, we had
Find the x values ​​that make up each of these equations
This matter is a little simpler
They only have to check one of the two
Let 's find a set of solutions for both
These and then find their unity
Any compound, any things that are
Check any of them
If in these, any existing on the left, we can
We add 1 for both parties
The left side becomes 4x>
= 7 + 1, ie 8
Divide both sides on 4
We get x> = 2
Or let us move on to these
Let us see, if we hit both ends of this equation with 2/9
What do we get?
If we hit both sides with 2/9, it is a positive number
So we do not have to do anything for these disparities
These are deleted, and we get x <3 × 2/9
3/9 equals 1/3, if x must
Be less than 2/3
Or that x <2/3
If this is a set solution
x> = 2, or x <2/3
this is interesting
Let me see the solution set on the setup line
If this is the setup line
Maybe this is the 0, this is the 1, this is 2, 3, maybe that is
-1
If x can be greater than or equal to 2
We can start - let me do this in a different color -
We can start from 2 here and it will be greater than or equal to
2, and thus include everything greater than or equal to 2
This is the condition here
Or that x can be less than 2/3
If 2/3 is almost here, is not it?
Those are 2/3
x can be less than 2/3
This is interesting
Because if we choose one of these numbers, you'll
Achieves this disparity
If we choose one of these numbers, you will achieve
Those disparate
If we have "and" here, you will not be here preparing
Check it out because it can not be both larger than 2
And less than 2/3
If the only way we get a set solution here is
Because there is "or" you can check one of these
The two
Anyway, I hope you found it fun